I'm doing very well I'm very excited  yeah I'm very excited it's my first red  carpet premiere which is what I think it  is the beginning was difficult because  there was a lot of work you had to do  and for me kind of made me realize what  I'd know and don't know so just kind of  getting rid of all the misconceptions i  had about filmmaking script writing in  all else was difficult I'm definitely  interested in educational resources so  video i think is one of the best mediums  to convey excitement about science and  mathematics so she's definitely  something that will be important in life  how would you describe this  you have a month to learn how to make an  educational video and then you get to  write produce direct and create at all  don't think it's going to be easy just  always think that it's going to be  harder than you expected and put work  into it